Star Köcher haben tausende Rezepte
zuletzt habe ich drei verschiedene Köche
antreten lassen in der Disziplin
Bolognese heute ist ein weiterer
Klassiker dran Burger eine Sache die ich
persönlich nicht auf die leichte
Schulter nehme ihr da draußen bestimmt
genauso wenig deshalb wird es heute
wirklich wirklich spannend unsere drei
Kandidaten sind Steffen Henssler Tim
Mälzer und Gordon Ramsay auf jeden Fall
drei Hochkaräter mit sehr interessanten
Rezepten ich habe ein bisschen an
Bewertungssystem gefallen weil da habt
ihr zurecht gesagt das war noch nicht
perfekt wir haben die Kategorien von
fünf auf drei reduziert einmal Aufwand
einmal kosten und einmal Geschmack für
Aufwand Kosten gibt's 5 Punkte und
Geschmack das wichtigste kann bis zu 10
Punkte erhalten genug erklärt genug
geredet fangen wir an mit dem ersten
Burger und der kommt von Tim Mälzer was
brauchen wir brauchen grüne Paprika rote
Paprika Gurke zwiebel Knoblauch für eine
Salsa das ist schon eine erste Eigenheit
das ist auf jeden Fall eher so ein
Premium Burger wir machen das dafür
schmeißen wir einfach alles hier in
diesen Mixer aber auch beim Patt später
spannend das ist auf jeden Fall ein
anderer Burger als sie ihn kennt so
einfach mal alles hineingeben dann mixen
wir das Ganze durch man sieht direkt die
Gurke ist da ein ganz ganz wichtiger
Komponenten die Flüssigkeit die hier
freigesetzt wird trägt natürlich gut
dazu bei dass das Ganze gemixt wird und
das Rezept ist von vor fünf Jahren auf
youtube ist glaube ich aber noch älter
er war auf jeden Fall Tim mälzern Burger
pioniert man muss schon sagen und das
muss man dem Rezept auch gedanklich
zugute halten dass es sich auf jeden
Fall viel getan hat in der Burger
Landschaft ich meine wer kannte vor zehn
Jahren z.B Smash Burger wir schütten das
einmal in Sieb und lassen unsere Zeit
ein bisschen abtropfen ist jetzt muss ja
aber auch sagen keine Augenweide ne die
Salsa ein bisschen Salz dazu
Feuchtigkeit rausstreichen wir lassen
das mal ein bisschen von selbst
abtropfen und kümmern uns um das Patty
Juicy Lucy ist ein wunderschöner Begriff
dafür dass man quasi zwei Patties hat
die aber zu einem hinzugefügt werden und
Käse umschließen der soll dann richtig
schön rausschmelzen ich habe hier 200
Gramm Rinder gehabt ist drei Scheiben
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal so die
Hälfte von meinem Hackfleisch packe die
auf die Unterseite weil ich knete
erstmal schön durch dass wir so eine
schöne Masse haben und dann forme ich
die untere Seite von unserem Juicy Lucy
Patty drücken das ganze jetzt schön
flach aus gleichmäßig flach ohne Löcher
weil der Käse soll idealerweise dann
auch drin bleiben später das ganze mache
ich auf dem anderen Blatt Backpapier
noch mal jetzt nehme ich mir hier zwei
scheibenbruar machen alles eins zu eins
wie Tim Mälzers gemacht hat wollen die
beste Vergleichbarkeit schaffen und
müssen natürlich auch am Originalrezept
bleiben ab und legt das hier ein
bisschen versetzt hinein jetzt kommt das
zweite Patty oben drauf dann kann ich
schon mal anfangen das hier so ein
bisschen zusammen zu drücken ist auf
jeden Fall ein ordentlicher apparello
geworden Hackfleisch zieht sich ja auch
immer gerne zusammen wenn man es an
dreht so sieht unser Patty aus alles
weitere auch der Frischkäse kommt später
einfach so aufs Band auch schon sehr
interessant möchte ich sagen wir machen
einmal den Herd an unser Plan ist schön
heißt ich gebe ein wenig Öl oben drauf
und dann folgt auch schon direkt unser
Patty 1 2 Minuten pro Seite braten ich
mache weiter mit der Salzer dafür werden
wir die ganze Flüssigkeit los die wollen
wir nicht die verbesserten Burger sagt
Tim geben den Rest einfach wieder in die
Schüssel zack jetzt geben wir dazu noch
zwei Esslöffel Senf ich probiere das
ganze mal
schöne Schärfe schöne frische schmeckt
jetzt nicht so besonders vollmundig oder
so ich gehe noch ein bisschen Salz dran
das fehlt noch jetzt flippen wir unser
Patty oh super Restaurant Petty hat sich
obwohl das sogar die größere Seite war
ein bisschen geöffnet der Käse ist aber
noch nicht ausgetreten also Gott sei
Dank haben wir noch Glück rösten wir
jetzt unsere Bands an nicht auf der
planscher wie ist eigentlich immer
machen würde sondern im Backofen der ist
auf 200 Grad vorgeheizt 1 2 Minuten
einfach rein wir nehmen einfach bei
allen Burger der Einfachheit und der
Vergleichbarkeit halber dieselben Bands
weil sonst würden wir drei sesamband
backen die auch immer wir machen das so
das sind die besten also eine Sache weiß
ich jetzt schon finde ich nicht perfekt
und zwar dass man das einfach im Ofen
anröstet mit bisschen Butter so eine
schöne knusprige Oberfläche zu schaffen
bei einem Band bringt auch jedenfalls
viel mit sich ich hole jetzt einmal die
Band drauf geröstet sind sie jetzt
wird's interessant Unterseite einfach
auf das Band Salat jetzt nehmen wir noch
ordentliche Schippe Frischkäse und
streichen die auf unser top waren
Frischkäse sagt Tim schmeckt frischer
als Mayonnaise auch schön fettig Patty
nehmen Käse drin sollte geschmolzen sein
wir legen das auf den Salat jetzt kommt
oben drauf ein richtiger Haufen von
unserer Salsa das meine ich das gewinnt
wahrscheinlich jetzt heutzutage keinen
schöner als Preis mehr jetzt macht Tim
sogar noch einfach Jalapenos drauf ich
glaube ich bin ein bisschen vorsichtig
und jetzt kommt einfach der Deckel drauf
und fertig ist der Tim Mälzer Burger was
für ein Video aber nicht gesehen haben
ist wie das Ganze schmeckt das testen
wir jetzt direkt möglicherweise machen
wir jetzt nicht die anderen zwei Burger
und stellen die neben dran sondern wir
testen wir bewerten ich bin sehr
gespannt darauf wir machen erstmal
klassischen mittelschnitt wir haben es
auf jeden Fall entsprechend nach Rezept
durchgebraten es sollte schön durch sein
Käse geschmolzen sein ja sieht gut aus
ich denke der Burger entspricht ziemlich
genau dem was er sein soll das gucken
wir mal ob der Geschmack meinen
Vorstellungen entsprechend
boah so anders als jeder Bürger den ich
in der letzten Zeit gegessen habe der
schmeckt gut auf jeden Fall du hast mir
die Hälfte jetzt mal schmecken eric ist
die andere wir besprechen uns dann
kommen wir zu Bewertung bevor wir zum
nächsten Burger kommen wenn man schon so
ein fettigen Burger ist sollte man
vielleicht nicht immer unbedingt eine
Cola dazu trinken sondern eher ab den
Sponsor des heutigen Videos ihr habt
vielleicht mitbekommen dass Dave und
auch ich jetzt gerade am durchziehen
sind regelmäßig Sport machen bisschen
gucken was wir uns zuführen und dabei
ist sowas wie Erben echter Helfer häufig
sind Sachen nicht das was sie scheinen
das hier ist z.B eine planscher das hier
ist ein Kochtopf aber das hier ist keine
einfache Wasserflasche er hat ein
spezielles System mit dem man Wasser
trinkt aber Geschmack ankommt weil ja
wir können einfach aus der Flasche
trinken wie aus jeder Flasche aber durch
unsere Sinne durch den Geruchssinn wird
Geschmack hervorgerufen das nennt man
Retro nasales riechen und so
funktioniert die ganze Sache hier in die
eigenes konzipierte Flasche füllt ihr
Wasser setzt dann den Trinkhalm drauf
ein Port oben drauf ich habe gerade
Mango Maracuja und wenn ihr den dann
hochzieht kann die Luft zirkulieren das
mal hin
und ihr schmeckt den Pott gerade die
ersten meiner als ich es ausprobiert
habe hat es mich wirklich überrascht
dass das funktioniert im Rachenraum wird
die beduftete Luft von unserem
riechtzentrum als Geschmack wahrgenommen
und so hast du deine Wahrnehmung an der
Nase herumgeführt die Pods gibt es in
unendlich vielen Geschmacksrichtungen
sei es Litschi passion fruit Maracuja
Mango Cola egal was dann könnt ihr euch
die Flasche konfigurieren wenn ihr jetzt
Lust auf mehr habt dann checkt er ab ab
klick den Link in der Videobeschreibung
vielen Dank an ihr habt fürs
unterstützen meines Kanals und dieses
Videos wir machen jetzt weiter mit dem
nächsten Burger und hier sind alle
Zutaten an Gemüse haben wir Gewürzgurken
Zwiebel Tomate Eisbergsalat ein bisschen
Ketchup einfach fertig Butter dann noch
ein Entrecote Bacon und chedder warum
haben wir einen Entrecote weil wir das
jetzt zu unserem Hackfleisch Wolfen das
ist eins zu eins zuvor gesehen und so
auch ein Video zu sehen man kann auch
fertiges benutzen sagt Steffen Fenster
aber das Ohr hat einfach direkt von Haus
aus dem schönen Fettanteil den brauchen
wir damit der Burger richtig gut
schmeckt so Steffen Fenster nach und
nach wollten das ganze hier schön grob
sind langsam aber sicher durch das sieht
auf jeden Fall schon schön aus so grob
gewollt frisch gewolft dass unsere
Ausbeute unser gewolftes Entrecote das
geben wir jetzt einmal in einen setzring
und Formen ist zu einem Patty ohne es zu
sehr anzudrücken ich glaube das gibt
auch schönen Charakter es soll
zusammenhalten aber trotzdem sehr sehr
luftig sein jetzt wird das ordentlich
gehört aber wirklich ordentlich mit Salz
und Pfeffer an der Seite wird auch
ordentlich gewürzt ich glaube sobald das
ganze halt mit ordentlich Hitze an dreht
dann kriegt es auch noch mehr Stabilität
die Hitze schaffen wir jetzt erstmal in
der Pfanne wir brauchen nämlich nur eine
Pfanne für das ganze Ding keine eigenen
zeitzers keine besonderen Soße in
unserer einen Pfanne machen wir zum
Beispiel gegrill Zwiebel dafür schneide
ich die Zwiebel erstmal jetzt schneiden
wir hier schöne Ringe runter schön dünn
damit die uns auch schnell garen gleich
dann brauchen wir noch eine Gewürzgurke
einfach der Länge nach den Streifen
geschnitten da kommt später ein Move mit
dem ich nicht gerechnet hätte vielleicht
für unsere Tomate schöne Scheiben
rausschneiden wir Pinseln unser Patti
jetzt mit Öl ein schön dünn wir wollen
das nicht Frittieren cooler Tag finde
ich weil dadurch kriegen wir auf jeden
Fall mehr Röstaromen als wenn wir das so
richtig Frittieren auch hier von beiden
Seiten wir nehmen unser Patty platzieren
es in der Pfanne ab jetzt wird es scharf
durchgebraten meinem entrecord darf es
auch ein bisschen blutig in der Mitte
sein sagt Steffen 2 Minuten später
können wir flippen gehen einmal
vorsichtig runter und legen das Patty
auf die andere Seite jetzt wird's Zeit
für unseren Bacon damit es auch schön
den Fleischsaft noch aufnimmt und hier
unten kommt eine Idee Butter hin und auf
die Butter wiederum unsere gegrillten
Zwiebeln und jetzt geben wir auch schon
mal Teil der chedder oben drauf so
richtig schöne instant gegrillte
Zwiebeln Butter macht alles gibt direkt
auch Farbe dran optisch schön den Becken
geben wir jetzt oben auf den Käse das
gibt auch alles noch von oben Hitze auf
unserer Patty bzw vor allem auf den Käse
der schmilzt und jetzt interessanter
move gewürzgurken in die Pfanne die
einfach mal schnell so durch die
radrückstände ziehen sind sie nicht mehr
ganz kalt aber haben natürlich ein
bisschen an Geschmack gewonnen und jetzt
nehmen wir unser Burger Patty eben das
hier auf einen Teller zum Ruhen während
der Ruhe noch mal Butter in die Pfanne
und die übrig gebliebenen bratrückstände
beim anrösten des Patties aufnehmen ich
glaube jetzt warten wir kurz bisschen
eine schöne Farbe haben kleine Info
Eisbergsalat waren Fake News brauchen
wir gar nicht hatten wir noch da stehen
sorry dann lass uns mal den Bad Boy
zusammenbauen so sieht das Ganze nach
ein zwei Minuten aus schöne Farbe dran
wir gehen auf beide Seiten Ketchup Ober
und Unterseite ordentlich Ketchup die
zweite Tomatenscheiben sind auf der
Unterseite platziert mit ein bisschen
Salz dran weil keine Tomate sollte ohne
Salz auskommen müssen und jetzt da
ziehen wir einfach Patty mitsamt allem
was du daherkommt oben drauf reicht das
ein bisschen aus und wir Grünen
vermeintlichen König optisch sexy
klassischer mittelschnitt da ist schon
wirklich viel Smart dran ne auch das z.B
während man die Band anröstet wenig rosa
drin das war tatsächlich bei Steffen im
Video auch so der Fett Gehalt
entschuldigt das ganze halt ne deutlich
weniger farbenfroh auf jeden Fall als
der erste Kandidat probieren wir
das ist eine sehr sehr sehr sehr saftige
Angelegenheit geiler biss man hat 0,0
dieses komprimierte was man nicht so
gerne mag das ist wirklich ein sehr sehr
guter Burger ich meine das klingt so als
würde ich gurgeln wenn ich diesen Burger
als das einfach so juicy wir machen uns
jetzt unsere Gedanken für die Bewertung
Rinderbrust drin das Schulter ich
schneide es klein und werfe es in den
Wolf hinein denn wir machen einen Gordon
Ramsey Burger aber auch hier müssen wir
natürlich Einkaufen Mama mir ey das
sieht wirklich sehr sehr schön aus ich
habe einmal mit Rinder Schulter und drin
da Brust Smash Burger gemacht auch
selbst gehäuften die haben wirklich
alles auseinander genommen das ist aber
kein Smash Burger was wir machen und vor
allem brauchen wir eine Sache die wir
hier in der Küche nicht haben einen
Grill deshalb geht's jetzt ab zu mir
nach Hause kommen wir nun zum dritten
Kandidaten neben Gordon ramsyburger ich
habe hierfür das Fleisch was wir gerade
zu Hause gewollt haben bzw ich bin zu
Hause und das war gerade im Büro das
gebe ich ja einmal in den setzring und
ich Form so richtig dicke oh schießt
also wie gerade eben eigentlich nicht zu
fest drücken jetzt Salzen wir das ganze
großzügig das ist ein Key fact über
Gordon Ramsay der Haut einfach überall
richtig ordentlich seasning drauf und
wir nehmen uns unsere Patties Burger
drauf wichtig laut Gordon direkt zu
klappen sogar sie natürlich von allen
Seiten aber die kriegen auch den nötigen
Halt denn wir müssen ja gleich auf dem
Grill wenden als nächstes Zwiebel schöne
dicke Streifen idealerweise schält man
sie vorher ein paar schöne Scheiben
Tomate schauen wir einmal rein wie sieht
das hier aus vorne am Rost ist der Grill
ja üblicherweise ein bisschen weniger
heiß da platziert er seine Burger Bands
und röstet die schon mal vorher fertig
an gute Idee das machen wir auch wir
Pinsel ein bisschen geschmolzene Butter
auf die Wand und wird sie sehen Pfeffer
und Salz aufmachen und andere Resten
fertig von beiden Seiten schön Farbe
passt nimmt sich noch mal seine Butter
und bepinselt sowohl die Burger als auch
die Zwiebeln unser Kleber kommt jetzt
ins Spiel noch mal zu machen das Ganze
schnell schmilzen bisschen runter mit
der Hitze ich ziehe mir jetzt hier
einmal alles auf mein Brettchen damit
ich gleich in Ruhe zusammenbauen kann
oben und unten gehen wir mit einer
dijon-senf-mayonnaise dran nehmen wir
uns unseren Salat snappen den das Patty
ist mein Wunschkind von den beiden Platz
hier das einmal oben drauf ist noch ein
paar gegrillte Zwiebeln und Gordon hat
so eine wunderschöne große Tomate habe
ich nicht gefunden wir nehmen zwei
kleine komprimieren das ganze und Grünen
den König es bleibt uns nur in
anzuschneiden gehen wir einmal rein das
geht wirklich durch die Butter so sieht
der Gordon RAM Sieger aus wir gehen rein
in die Masse
boah jetzt sind jetzt zum ersten Mal
eine Sache steht fest es wird unfassbar
schwer einen Gewinner zu ermitteln wir
hatten drei wirklich gute Burger
interessante Burger außergewöhnliche
Burger kommen wir zur finalen
Punktevergabe erste Kategorie Aufwand
Melzer Burger relativ viele Zutaten ein
zwei Sachen zu spülen aber unfassbar
schnell deshalb würde ich den Aufwand
relativ geringe einschätzen und vier von
fünf möglichen Sternen geben Henssler
genauso eine Pfanne aber wir müssen
selbst Wolken was schon auch ein
bisschen Act ist deshalb eigentlich noch
einfacher aber Zusatzaufwand 4 Ramsi mit
dem Grill viel bestreichen viel zu
verschieben zu überblicken schon der
aufwendigste von allen drei von fünf die
Kosten Mälzer Burger kostet 6 € pro
Portion vier von fünf möglichen Punkten
Henssler kostet mit dem Entrecote 9 €
pro Portion drei von fünf Möglichkeit
jetzt die wichtigste Kategorie Geschmack
bis zu zehn mögliche Punkte bei Mälzer
gebe ich 7 mir fehlt einfach ein
bisschen so dieses wo man sich reinlegen
kann das war schön frisch das war
abwechslungsreich aber das war für mich
persönlich nicht das was ein Burger
ausmacht beim Henssler waren wir
verdammt nah dran knusprig umami
fleischig neun von zehn Punkten das war
wirklich Gordon Ramsay macht ganz viel
ähnlich wie Steffen Henssler ist fehlt
aber trotzdem noch so eine Nuance ich
weiß nicht ob das der Bacon ist aber
irgendwie war der noch kranker im
Geschmack von Steffen Henssler acht für
Golden sie und ich bin nicht gekauft
wenn ich sage dass wieder Steffen
Henssler gewonnen hat heute war es auch
wirklich einfach der Geschmack das war
richtig krass richtig lecker deshalb
Steffen noch mal Glückwunsch hör auf zu
kommentieren dann denken die Leute dass
ich dir den Sieg schenke es war wirklich
einfach der beste Burger ein weiteres
Starkoch Battle ist zu Ende gegangen
welches Gericht sollen wir als nächstes
machen schreibst in die Kommentare bis
zum nächsten Mal hier ist ein für dich
vorgeschlagenes Video darunter kannst du
den Kanal abonnieren mach es bitte
tschüss frisches Fleisch vom Metzger
kostet Geld schmeckt es besser ja ist am
31.12 Silvester ja okay ich schneide das
Chuck du kaufst preground du peinlicher
Sack habe ich dich mit meinem Burger
neidisch gemacht dann können wir einfach
einen Sub kriegst du auch solche Burger
in deinem peinlichen Kaffee trinkst du
water mit er ab oder heimlich deinen
Saft Fragen die ich mir stelle